ممكن لسرقه فلوس المصريين الثمانينيات انت
عارف المصري همم بيروح الخليج السعوديه
الكويت
الامارات يعني ويرجع
ودول هم اللي عملوا الطبقه المتوسطه مش
هيشتغل بقى معندوش مخ تجاري عايز احطهم في
البنك فكان كان بدات شركات توظيف الاموال
تطلع اللي هي لها غطاء اسلامي كويس وكانت
بتديك 20% وساعات 25 طبعا البنك دي 15 10
حاجات كده فبدا هو يعمل غطاء شرعي يقول
انه الفلوس البنوك ربا
ويزكي هؤلاء ما هم خلاص قلت لي فلوس انا
عايز اعيش ومعايا مثلا جاي معايا فلوس من
السعوديه وعايز اكمل حياتي يبقى احطهم في
بنك يجيب لي فلوس لو قلت لي ربع وبعدين
كمان اقل خدي بالك ان انه البنوك بتدي اقل
من الشركات توظيف الاموال فكل فمجرد غطاء
شرعي من شيخ زي الشعراوي
هيخليك كمصري تجري تحط فلوسك ده يعني بكل
المقاييس ما فيش فيها هزار انا عايز ابقى
اقول افرق بين حاجتين عشان الناس ساعات لا
تفرق في فرق بين الشيخ الامام الشعراوي
لما يفسر القران
بثقافته
كمان استاذ في اللغه العربيه
وعنده سحر وفهم وعمق حاجه دي ما ليش دعوه
بها لان انا لا استطيع ان اجادل قام وقيمه
زي الشعراوي
لكن انا هنا لا اتحدث عن تفسير القران
انا اتحدث هنا عن اجتهاده في قضايا قد
تصيب وقد تخطئ وازاي انا لما انا اقول
فيها ممكن ابقى انا خطا وهو يبقى صح بس
فزي حكايه الربا اعتبارها ربا ما ده ده
بالنسبه لي لا انا شايف ان هو مش منطق لما
مثلا حكايه الاعضاء نقل الاعضاء اعتبر
انها حرام لانك انت يعني وجهه نظري وانك
انت لا تملك اعضائك بتاعه ربنا او بعد
الموت خلاص فازاي تقول انا هتبرع تتبرع
فيما لا تملكه طبعا ده ضد العلم وضد
الحياه وهكذا بهذا الامر اعتقد تحدث عن
الموضوع غسيل الكلى كمان وانه الكولا طب
انت ليه بتاجل بتاجل لقائك بربنا ما تغسلش
يعني مش ممكن انت يبقى لك انسان عزيز عليك
بتحبه ابنك ابوك امك تعمل غسيل كلوي وتقول
مش هعمل لها عشان تلحق تقابل ربنا بسرعه
يعني في حاجات كتيره كانت بتصدمنا طب
مناقل الدم ليه طب ما هو النقل ما هو الدم
عضو مش كده طب ليه ليه بحلق نقل الدم ما
تعرضش ليه طب ما نفس الحكايه لو فتحنا
المساله لما تمنع النقل الدم كمان جزء من
الجسد من انسان دم يعني بتاخد مني انا
اسكت انا لا املكه